Would Will Smith need to be de-aged, or is
that infamous alternate ending going to come
into play?
What megastar is joining Smith?
All that and more, right here!
In 2007, Will Smith once again cemented his
place as one of Hollywood's most charismatic
movie stars when he played the lead in "I
Am Legend."
The film takes place in a post-apocalyptic
world where most humans have either been wiped
out or turned into vampiric mutants known
as Darkseekers.
"I Am Legend" follows the efforts of Smith's
Dr. Robert Neville, the sole human living
in an overrun Manhattan, as he tries to find
a cure for the disease that changed the world
and, hopefully, link up with other human survivors.
The movie is a loose adaptation of the 1954
Richard Matheson novel of the same name.
"I Am Legend" was a box office success when
it was released in December 2007, earning
over $585 million worldwide, according to
BoxOfficeMojo.
Plus, it received generally positive reviews
from both critics and casual moviegoers alike.
Now, over a decade after the first film's
release, Will Smith is set to star in an "I
Am Legend" sequel, and he isn't the only notable
actor attached to the project.
In March 2022, Deadline reported that Smith
had signed on to star in and executive produce
a sequel to "I Am Legend."
Shortly after the report's release, Smith
seemingly confirmed the news on Instagram
when he posted an image of the post-apocalyptic
version of Manhattan from the first film.
In addition to Smith, the sequel will also
star "Black Panther" and "Creed" actor Michael
B. Jordan, who is set to executive produce
the film alongside his co-star.
Akiva Goldsman, who co-wrote the 2007 adaptation
of "I Am Legend," is set to write the sequel.
However, it's unclear if "I Am Legend" filmmaker
Francis Lawrence will return to helm the sequel,
or if it'll be another filmmaker who ultimately
sits in the director's seat for the follow-up.
The film's plot is similarly unknown right
now, and it does not currently have a set
release date.
Asked about the announcement in a recent interview
with Entertainment Tonight, Smith teased,
"I can't talk about it yet.
But it's a really, really cool concept and
[Michael B. Jordan] was a part of creating
the idea.
[…] It was one of those [movies] I was gonna
leave alone."
Smith also admitted that he quickly reconsidered
once he heard the pitch for the sequel.
As he told Entertainment Tonight, he remembers
thinking,
"'But that might work.
I think we can do that.'"
With two massive stars like Jordan and Smith
attached to the project, it seems safe to
assume that it won't take too long for more
updates and details to start surfacing about
"I Am Legend 2."
One of the updates that "I Am Legend" fans
are undoubtedly most curious about is how
Smith plans to appear in the upcoming film,
especially considering his character's apparent
death at the climax of the first movie.
While no plot details about the film have
been released as yet, that leaves plenty of
room for speculation.
"Just fishing in the dark son."
One potential answer could involve a mixture
of flashbacks and de-aging software to return
Dr. Neville back to his pre-apocalyptic or
mid-apocalyptic image.
There likely remains plenty of story to be
told about the immediate three years after
the outbreak of the Krippin Virus.
Of course, Smith is no stranger to Hollywood's
de-aging practices as a result of his role
in 2019's "Gemini Man," a film which sees
Smith's character battle a younger version
of himself.
Admittedly, however, this might be one of
the more predictable avenues writers could
employ.
Another possible route that returns Dr. Neville
to the big screen involves an alternate ending
to the original 2007 film.
The theatrical cut of "I Am Legend" sees Dr.
Neville sacrifice himself in order to save
a cure for the future of mankind.
On its face, this scene is extremely unambiguous,
and by the end of the theatrical cut, Dr.
Neville is dead.
However, ardent fans of the film will also
surely remember an alternate ending included
on the DVD release.
In addition to proving popular online, the
alternate ending is noted for its closer dedication
to the source material.
Instead of concluding with a dramatic sacrifice,
this ending presents Dr. Neville with the
opportunity to make peace with the Darkseekers
he has been trying to "cure" for so long.
Realizing that his experiments have instead
made him the monster, Dr. Neville abandons
his research and home.
Making peace with his new reality, Dr. Neville
instead opts to join a group of human survivors
in Vermont.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.